je considère que dans les débats de
société qui sont les nôtres et qui sont
complexes les mots ont du sens comprenez
vous la haine anti-flic qui existent en
banlieue le mot haine et le mot anti
flics ne paraissent pas conformes à ce
que la situation devrait devrait être la
colère à l'égard de certaines fonctions
de police qui font état de violences oui
à n'en pas douter on a le droit et on
doit être en colère de voir certaines
fonctions de police faire état d'une
violence qui n'est pas légitime ne que à
l'égard de certains jeunes ou à l'égard
même de certains adultes dans notre pays
globalement quartier ou pas quartier
mais la haine anti-flic je trouve que ça
ne ça ne correspond pas à la réalité
pourquoi d'abord le lan et s'était moqué
très fort ce jeudi à cesser
c'est la volonté de vouloir ce qu'il ya
de plus grave et de plus je dirais le
mal le plus fort à l'égard de la
personne qui situe en face de toi anti
flics ça essentialise c'est toute la
corporation policière
moi je peux pas d'accord avec ça moi
encore une fois qu'on soit en colère
connaît la rage contre ceux qui ne
respectent pas les codes de déontologie
ce qui tutoie facilement ceux qui font
état de violences ceux qui se prennent
pour des caïds ou des cow boys alors
qu'ils sont porteurs de la règle et de
la loi républicaine cela d'abord ce sont
des brebis galeuses pour moi qui n'ont
rien à faire dans la police mais ils
sont une infime minorité et l'immense
majorité des fonctions de police font
leur travail me semble-t-il
convenablement dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles et la notion d'
anti-flics oublie cela et je ne veux pas
les oublier
je ne veux pas les englober daad avec
ceux qui aujourd'hui des rats c'est
comme si on disait comprenez vous la n2
contre les jeunes de banlieue sous
prétexte qu'il y aura une minorité de
trafiquants ont nourri une haine contre
les jeunes de banlieue alors que
l'immense majorité des jeunes des
banlieues veut trouver sa place dans la
cité française et se lèvent le matin
fait du sport à l'université bas à
l'école et en lycée professionnel sont
respectueux des règles de la loi il
faudrait qu'on ait la rage contre ces
jeunes parce qu'une infime minorité en
fait c'est le règne des minorités qui
nous fait mal dans ce pays le règne des
minorités on a une minorité de jeunes
qui ne respectent pas la règle c'est qui
et avec qui j'ai envie de dire même
genre et agite les choses je suis pour
qui le chaos organisé ce trafic
mais c'est pas lui
n c'est une minorité de jeunes et on ne
peut pas parce qu'il ya une minorité de
jeunes allaient attaquer tous les jeunes
et leur faire dit contrôle dans la
journée
alors qu'on ne sait pas qui ils sont
alors david et qui se sait atteint 6,1
mais il va me répondre mais si je peux
aller au bout donc parce que j'ai écouté
tout le monde est quand même assez
attentivement de crise toujours réfléchi
vous pouvez le dire mais c'est un peu
désagréable d'être coupée jeudi à 14
meetings nos pensées moi j'ai été
policier du miso l'intérieur ses pages
aux pc jean pierre chevènement qu'amiens
place la police de proximité
j'ai été son conseiller à l'époque il ya
vingt ans c'était 1199 la police de
proximité contre un masque dit laurent
seillier c'est pas un échec
c'est qu'on n'a pas donné les moyens aux
fonctions de police qui sont la sécurité
publique d'être suffisamment nombreux
affecté à un territoire
mais c'est très important ce que je dis
là pourquoi parce que la police qui ne
connaît pas son territoire c'est la
police qui à un moment donné ce sens en
milieu hostile et qui confondent tout
qui sait plus faire la part des choses
entre le petit voyou et la personne
honnête
or aujourd'hui les interventions
policiers en banlieue ne peuvent pas se
limiter aux compagnies républicaines de
sécurité ou à la bac
ils ne peuvent pas on a besoin parfois
de compagnies républicaines de sécurité
et de la bac parfois mais il faut
d'abord une police qui crée des ponts à
qui élèvent des murs
or aujourd'hui on a un climat qui doit
être celui de la réconciliation de la
restauration de la confiance
est-ce que l'intervention policière tels
que la manoeuvre est là pour restaurer
la confiance
moi je ne le crois pas je crois qu'on
utilise mal nos fonctions de police et
du coup on les met dans des conditions
très difficiles et on met les habitants
des quartiers dans les mêmes conditions
parce que les uns et les autres ne se
connaissent pas et aussi ce ce que la
défiance provoque comme effets
dévastateurs
il nous faut une police qui connaît son
territoire qui sache faire la part des
choses et qu'ils fassent respecter
l'ordre républicain et qui ne confondent
pas tout le monde qu'il n'a mal gamme
pas c'est fondamental parce
qu'aujourd'hui les habitants des
quartiers quartier permettez moi de vous
dire ils ont besoin de la police nous on
a même vision de rejoindre de la police
et mais ils ont besoin d'une épaule et
ce dans le 15e j le connaisse qui les
respecte et qui encore une fois élimine
ce qui crée le trouble dans ces
quartiers et qu'ils fassent que des
habitants des quartiers vivent bien et
dans de bonnes conditions
moi je vous le dis tranquillement
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui profitent
du chaos et qui profitent de la
situation je suis assez effrayés
pour ne pas dire très inquiet de voir
qu'il faille un film pour que le
président de la république se rende
compte de la situation dans notre pays
c'est quand même très inquiétant alors
que c'est des situations qui dure depuis
des décennies
or aujourd'hui dans ses banlieues tu
peux pas mettre simplement comme service
public la police nationale on a quand
même besoin à un moment donné par le
retour des services publics avec un
grand s est un grand p la police
nationale bien sûr parce qu'on a besoin
de sécurité
c'est la première des libertés allez
venir tranquillement mais on a besoin
aussi d'un service d'éducation renforcés
avec des personnels enseignants soutenus
de la santé dans ces quartiers
aujourd'hui on voit bien que on a plus
de réponses de santé il ya des
problématiques d'ainsi quartier on ne
peut pas abandonner ce territoire de la
république les travaux on ne peut pas
les abandonner et bernard pour conclure
disais quelque chose d'important
quand vous avez 50 à 60 % de chômage
dans une zone ou pas et c'est qu'on peut
vivre de manière sereine apaisée mais
c'est pas possible on a 8 % de chômage
dans le pays ont créé la catastrophe et
à 60 pour cent dans certains quartiers
et pourtant on peut pas dire que tout le
monde ne veut pas se lever le matin ne
veut pas bosser il y en a comme dans le
reste du pays
mais l'immense majorité de brousse et me
soulever de trouver sa place mais quand
tu mens et cv qu'on dit à le patronyme
ça va pas l'adresse autres sensible ça
peut pas durer ça vous ne pas durer de
connacht on utilise pour le aujourd'hui
on se prend des deux voies on a
aujourd'hui un devoir je le dis j'ai
utilisé l'expression créer des pommes
plutôt que d'élever des murs on ne peut
plus isolés ces quartiers du reste du
pays
c'est pas possible on ne peut plus
laisser la police nationale exercé comme
elle le fait dans des conditions
difficiles
il ya des brebis galeuses dans les
quartiers dans les allées d'alda la
police moi je voudrais dire juste un
chiffre à ce qu on me oui il ya 3000
sanction de parole de l'inspection
générale de la police nationale ont des
flottes de fonctions de police
on peut considérer que la justice et pas
assez dur lorsqu'il y a effectivement
bavure avéré violences avérées crime
parce que quand c'est intentionnel que
la justice le dis je parle pas des
affaires en cours je parle quand elle
l'a dit oui on peut considérer peut-être
qu'elle est passée c'est bien mais
encore une fois nous ne donnons pas le
sentiment ceux qui nous écoutent
notamment aux jeunes qui se passe jamais
rien contre les policiers
henin qui sont radiés il y en a qui
perdent leur job il y en a qui
donc n'exerçait plus ça existe il y à
des sanctions alors peut-être pas
suffisamment peut-être pas suffisamment
forte
mais ça existe donc non je voudrais pas
qu'on soit manichéen elle n'a pas les
bons d'un côté de mauvais de l'autre et
re sic à rien aujourd'hui le règne des
minorités il faut que les majorités
reprennent le dessus parce qu'il ya déjà
bien à la police ils sont majoritaires
il ya des jeunes viennent avec artie
shaw majorité